quand garlaban alou 4 p o et samba blum
anteo prennent à bias haut et court elle
l'est qu'en gare la dent à son chapeau
et sainte baume son manteau panda besace
et court vite
oui bien sûr vous aviez deviné même si
vous n'êtes pas né en provence
il suffit d'y avoir vécu quelques années
d'avoir respiré l'air de nos colis
d'avoir planer sur nos marchés pour être
bercé des sonorités de notre langue et
de la finesse de notre culture l'accent
ça s'attrape si vite
oui mais la provence madame ne s'arrête
pas à l'accent est dans notre midi
lorsque vous parlez français est bien
souvent vous parlez provençal sans le
savoir vous en doutez eh bien sans aller
bien loin
regarder et surtout écoutez bien
en revanche l'ump jean-luc pourquoi tu
vois pas qui lâche alassane casque je
lui ai dit de le faire m et il va se
partir j'adore quatre timbres avec
maison partir
pas que vous fait un petit tour mettre
le casque est fortement sur la chance de
voir qu'apple la question nous méprendre
à vos régions
on discutera là bas
et
oui il a un cap et il est tombé sur un
nageur indulgent ça aussi ça fait partie
de la province
mais entre nous messieurs qui de vous ne
s'est jamais faire payer un mot qui lui
vient ce qui veut dire qu'il ne soit pas
nécessaire que je vous l'expliquais sera
plus difficile peut-être pour le verbe
chalets se faire transporter
gratuitement à l'arrière d'un véhicule
et bien pendant que vous cherchez allant
faire un tour du côté d'aubagne pour
retrouver les sonorités de nos valeurs
ici l'expression provençal sont chez
elles et la musique de l'accent les
habits dans leur cadre naturel
camaïeu des toitures grillés par le
soleil et que la big wave des génoises
viendra coudre avec le ciel ruelle tour
à tour fraîche mais ensoleillée où le
linge flotte comme autant d'étendards
intime au pied du garlaban il est encore
bien vivant dans ceux dépendant des
provinces d'ailleurs au pays des santons
pourrait-on pétrir l'argile samedi mais
les démos polonceau il y a 6 l'homme
dans carrefour rio l'air fait vieille
langue que les mots ce sont moulés sur
chaque détail
mais non elle ne date pas de 17 172 la
vieille chapelle mai 2007 c'est tantôt
douces c'est tellement plus joli et puis
voyons les symptômes vous écoute comme
il écoute depuis toujours les hommes le
prière en provençal qui donnent entre
crochets sont montés dans le ciel au
cours des siècles
dans des cantiques aussi trouvé ça au
cas où vit la cam gomis à mao
que voulez vous ici le bon dieu ne
comprend que le provençal
après tout c'est notre langue du caire
nous ah oui je sais il y à l'académicien
impassible sous outrages des pigeons
aubagne et mais qui nous dit que tout
bas sous sa moustache de pierre ils ne
les méritent pas un bronzage
on est si loin du quai conti ici hein
mais ne croyez pas qu'il n'y ait que les
statuts pour parler notre langue à non
nous avons aussi le bel poissonnière à
aubagne
vous allez voir
le regard du 4e étage de bassin
du poisson inattendu mais aussi parce
que prendre pour ces personnes vous avez
du chef de gouvernement constitutionnel
et nrj mobile et call in europe ou des
actionnaires
il appelle à ce que l'essence de café
leur niveau de capital lancée le cusems
bleus-là suffit de caténaire y en aura
pour tous et là nous avons une belle
récolte pas et vous avez reconnu le
concombre derrière
hélas et le grand bain derrière la
cabine est et puis vous savez que les
favoris ce sont des crabes et pourquoi
que vous ayez été d'une imposante salle
vous savez que les suspects ce sont de
petites sèche et que là-bas nast c'est
le panier du pêcheur bien en 2010
mais pendant que nous allons vous
imprégner de l'annoncé à du marché je
vous donne un conseil la prochaine fois
que vous irez chez votre poissonnier
demandé vie des capellans sur leurs
appellations françaises
oui demandez-lui des glad bléneau id
pouvoir capter
les seconds
chasse fait pas mon bon monsieur qu'est
ce que vous voulez que je vous donne et
que je regardais cette semaine et qui
elles sont douces et où des clémentines
vous voulez des clientes et ne tenait
qu'aux banane habite
regardez moi ça c'est une beauté de
bananes voulait défendre
oui qu'est-ce qu'on le tourne à mes pas
m'ont alors je vous en donne un kilo
ça valait facile 2 1 elle est passée
devant alors celle là peut-être
une fronde 30
puis merci dit
vous l'avez vie celui-là lignes 7 et
francine et il me les charges peut tout
autre pour acheter une main non ne
croyez pas d'idées qui tout juste si
maintenant le temps de badar
et oui cette astra signe que vous les
retrouve on ne veut pas être un balès et
puis j'ouvre mes travaux sur divers
aspects ce mot qui était tellement
d'actualité aux heures d'affluence sur
l'étrave à marseille autrefois vous
souvient-il les dab
et puis le bada albada si le mot est
resté lusage sam et bien perdu où sont
les treize à la douzaine par sept ans de
vie chère
mais me direz-vous si visage la langue
provençale c'est continuer chez notre
fils hier qui a grandi à l'ombre du
clocher d'aubagne
comment se fait-il que la lance sont
encore employées chez les enfants que se
passe-t-il dans les écoles et bien pour
le savoir nous sommes allés près
d'aubagne à baudinard la ravissante
écoles de voiliers sans eau
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que kid koala
est alors pourquoi tu ne le dit pas un
français qui tous deux encore oui parce
qu'il ya images scannées mes billets je
connais tu dis qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ce qui m'a amené byrs
mais alors tu parles province elle ne
savait pas pensé à moi pour être après
les pouvoirs quand vous attrapez baumann
aut nous allons non donc là je me classe
qu'est ce que ça veut dire je clave salé
pas dû prendre cette l'état dans le plat
et justement il ne faut pas tout
mélanger
ou tu parle français ou tu parles
provençal mais pas les deux à la fois
mais puisque tunisienne tap dix mois en
province à ce que nous fait chier tous
les deux pascal minimum la différence
n'est ce couvent
il est certain c'est pas ça tu es avec
l'avare world
et bien c'est justement leur du cours de
provençal à les rejoindre votre classe
allez les enfants entrant avancé
en voilà qui parleront pour en salle
mais en sachant